people along Florida's east coast are
rushing to load up on water food and
emergency supplies our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is there
ahead of the storm in Cocoa Beach David
good morning good morning I was just
turning around looking at the people on
the beach it's a beautiful morning here
we got out of Puerto Rico on the last
flight out of town and I just confirmed
with FEMA that they're now relocating
teams that had been sent to Puerto Rico
and moving them here to Florida
the official I spoke to just a moment
ago said listen if we learn nothing else
about durian and the Caribbean it's that
it moved around so much we couldn't
really be sure where it was going to go
until less than 12 hours before landfall
so they're gonna pre position teams in
Tallahassee two teams in Atlanta have
them ready to move up and down the
southeast coast as Dorian gets closer
when Dorian hit the US Virgin Islands it
brought with it heavy rain and winds the
storm caused widespread outages but no
major damage
it is now strengthening and could be a
major category three storm by the time
it makes landfall in Florida on Labor
Day we just get ready that's it
Puerto Rico dodged a bullet as the storm
changed course at the last minute
Floridians are being told don't take a
chance I'm not that concerned but I
think it's better to be safe than sorry
I went through Andrew and I lost my
house so that made me ready
Florida's governor Ron de santis is
asking people to stock up with seven
days worth of supplies have a plan B
READY and listen we'll get more I think
resolution and certainty of over the
next 24-48 hours I'm not watching the
weather I'm not going to obsess about it
I'm I'm gonna pray my way through it
because God's in control I know that you
know here in Central Florida there are
hundreds of thousands of Puerto Ricans
who had been watching what was happening
on their beloved island and were happy
to see that they really didn't get much
of a hit at all and now they're getting
ready for the storm moving here Gayle
the big news in Puerto Rico everybody
breathing a sigh of relief they thought
it was going to be a big deal and it
turned out to be thankfully a big old
nothing sometimes a big old nothing is
good I'm trying to figure out where the
people are on the beach there David and
why would you come to the beach knowing
a hurricane is coming I'll get it hey
you got 72 hours get ready alright thank
you David bag no always good to see you